einen wunderschönen guten Abend wird gern
also darf ich darf ich jemanden grüßen vorweg
da
hallo Mama
da guckst du was jetzt war hier ich weiß
nicht hast du gesehen tatsächlich puffpaff
hast du mir nicht geglaubt aber ihr erzählt
dürfen Lied bei Puffer spielen manche nur gelacht
ausgelacht hat sie mich irgendwas
von dem schwulen Drachen erzählt
[Musik]
und dann sind wir dabei und ich werde SPD
und dann sind wir dabei und ich werde CDU
was willst du ich liebe von allein und
dich lieb Andrea Nahles ich werde mich
kaum entscheiden können wenn endlich wieder Wahl
ist ich liebe Wolfgang Schäuble und ich liebe
Roland Koch nee doch ich finde die eigentlich
alle ganz okay meine Mama kommt ganz gerne
[Applaus]
danke danke
ich liebe Horoskope und ich lese dir
zu was liest du morgens mag ich eure
Sport und nachts ich mag kämpfen ich liebe RTL
Sat.1 Pro7 QVC ich komme mir recht schlau vor
wenn ich warte sie ich finde die eigentlich
alle ganz okay meine Mama kommt ganz gerne
ein paar Jahren Rente er sitzt den
ganzen Tag auf dem WC die Zeitung [Musik]
fühlt sich einen Avocado Stein zu
primeter in den glatt rasierten
Anus ein neue Nachrichten vom grimmelkomitee
Halligalli Bunga Bunga ich mag Beckenbauer
[Musik]
[Musik] kommt ganz gerne ich finde die eigentlich
alle ganz okay meine Mama kocht ganz gerne
[Musik]
mama sagte einfach nie ich koche frei nach
Schnauze wenn ich doch such dann suche ich
lieber in mit TNG jetzt kommen wir zu Euch
noch mal ich habe euch alle lieb wenn ich
euch so sehe denke ich mir nur Pipi ich würde
euch gern behalten komm ich lad euch alle ein
und meine Mama tut uns was zu essen rein ich
finde das eigentlich alle ganz okay meine Mama
kommt ganz gerne ich finde euch eigentlich alle
ganz okay meine Mama kommt ganz gerne [Musik]